c'est donc la réhabilitation à des sites
universitaires le projet il est porté
entre autres par l'État la Région à la
métropole je vous propose qu'on regarde
le reportage sur les taneur et on
revient sur Polytech dans quelques
instants le début d'un chantier qui
était très attendu à l'université de
tour le retrait symbolique du premier
carreau de revêtement du site d'étaneur
a eu lieu ce matin car une partie de ces
locaux qui date des années 70 va être
entièrement rénové une bonne nouvelle
pour les étudiants qui constatent chaque
jour un peu plus leur dégradation par
exemple au niveau isolation c'est pas
forcément ça donc l'hiver il fait très
froid enfin on garde nos manteaux
systématiquement c'est pas confortable
pour travailler c'est vraiment aussi les
l'extérieur qui qui menace un peu de
s'effondrer tout ça vieillissant tout
est vieillissant on dirait que ça tombe
en rine un peu enfin surtout la façade
une façade qui avait dû être mise sous
filet car des morceaux de revêtements
menaçaient de chuté alors celui-ci va
être entièrement refait ainsi que les
accès PMR et l'isolation des bâtiments B
et D qui accueillent la BU et les plus
vieux amphithéâtres des travaux qui
devraient permettre de réduire de 30 %
les dépenses énergétiques de ce travail
commence donc par enlever ce qui est pas
tombé puisque on voit bien que il y a
des petits grillages qui ont été posés
on va complètement vider ce bâtiment
enfin voilà enlever toute la la peau
extérieure phase par phase et la
reconstituer reconstituer l'enveloppe en
changeant les menuiseries en changeant
la pierre qui habille la façade et en
intercalant dans tout ça les bonnes
isolations qui vont faire que le
bâtiment va être environnementalement
beaucoup plus performant l'intérieur de
la bibliothèque sera aussi entièrement
réaménagé avec l'intégration d'un espace
de coworking de salalles de formation et
de nouveaux bureaux elle disposera aussi
d'une entrée indépendante côté Loire
permettant de nouvell plage d'ouverture
pour les étudiants mais aussi les
habitants de la métropole enfin le
parvitelem sera aussi flamban neuf une
image de modernité positive pour
l'université notamment pour on va dire
l'international en plus là on vient
juste de rentrer dans une université
européenneuniversité néolaya je pense
que ça constituera on va dire un facteur
d'attractivité supplémentaire coût total
des travaux 22,8 million d'euros financé
à hauteur de 100 millions par la région
centrreev-de Loire de 3 millions par
tour métropole et le reste par l'État et
l'université la fin des travaux et la
mise en service sont attendu pour la
rentrée universitaire